like honestly
i'm having a proper full-on gay crisis
heartstopper has introduced the world to
kit connor the young star who plays nick
nelson on the must-see netflix show the
lgbtq plus young love story has already
been renewed for a second and third
season kit joined the reign with josh
smith podcast where he talked about
working with olivia coleman his
friendship with his co-star joe locke
and labeling his sexuality and me and
charlie
we
we're going out
and i just
wanted you to know
oh baby
no thank you for telling me in heart
stopper kit's on-screen mother is played
by none other than olivia coleman the
oscar-winning actress and the young star
share a pretty intimate scene where
kitt's character nick comes out as
bisexual kitt reveals he found out
olivia would be playing his mother three
weeks before shooting and describes the
experience in which he was mesmerized by
coleman's incredible talent
and then suddenly like a tear was
rolling down our face like as we were
just reading through the lines
so i was thinking
oh my god like this is i you know how am
i gonna how am i gonna compete with this
i need you to know that
my life is way better because i met you
the young star also talked about his
friendship with his co-star joe locke
who plays his love interest charlie and
now the two lean on each other for
support while navigating their newfound
fame it's very helpful to have another
person who's your age who's also just
starting to go through these experiences
because you can just sort of discuss it
so i think yeah i mean having joe
you know by my side has been
extraordinarily useful and helpful kit
also touched on his own experience with
people assuming his sexuality having
previously tweeted twitter is so funny
man apparently some people on here know
my sexuality better than i do he went on
to explain how being so young and
feeling this pressure and assumption
about his sexuality is invasive and
shouldn't truly matter especially in
2022 the actor went on to explain why
he's not big on labels
i mean for me i just feel like i'm
perfectly
you know confident and comfortable in my
sexuality but i don't feel the need to
really you know
i'm not
too big on label labels and things like
that i'm not massive about that and i
don't feel like i need to label myself
especially not publicly
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews click subscribe
or watch these videos